i never freeze
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man
in this video we're breaking down the
insane details in black panther if that
terrible impression at the start didn't
offend you
then thanks for sticking around because
we've got some great easter eggs to go
over that show
just how much effort marvel put into
their movies obviously there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to check out the movie yet
then
i hope you get dusted in the snapper
because we're going to be going over
everything
as always smash that thumbs up button if
you love wakanda forever
and make sure you subscribe to the
channel for videos like this every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our black
panther breakdown
okay so black panther opens with a
narration that tells of the meteorite
that hit wakanda
many millennia ago it enriching the
earth and five tribes settled in the
area
building advanced technological weapons
and they pretty much put the precious
metal in everything that they owned
vibranium is of course a material that's
laced throughout the mcu
and it was famously used to create
captain america's shield
this was thought to be pretty much
indestructible however black panther
actually managed to cut it in civil war
due to the fact that his claws are made
of the metal too
the indentation in the earth that the
meteorite leaves can also be seen in the
film
namely as the location where the final
battle takes place
and it's clear that the natives built
themselves up around it
in this introduction there's also a
mention of the panther god blast
and bast is a true deity and it features
in the mcu as the god that granted the
black panther with their abilities
t'challa himself likely follows the
religion of it too
as in the film just before the car scene
the character says
for best sake instead of for god's sake
it is likely that all tribes worship
their own gods as
when ambaku first shows up he says glory
to hanuman
hanuman is a monkey god and baku refers
to himself as the great gorilla
and also dons a mask of the animal too
cementing this notion
we learn that this narration is actually
being told to a young eric killmonger
and that he and his father have left the
kingdom
which we see in the opening scene this
is where we cut to oakland in 1992
and watch a young eric playing
basketball with a diy
basket at the end of the film arthur
t'challa has bought the property
the basketball hoop is replaced with a
real one showing the redevelopment
that's gone on in the area since he
acquired it
now this opening is laced with a lot of
subtle details but it basically
sets up the rivalry between t'challa and
killmonger due to the choices of both
their fathers
to me the bloodlines sort of represent
martin luther king and malcolm x
as they both have opposing ideologies on
how to get things done
t'challa is more of a peaceful man
that's trying to unite with the people
whereas killmonger wishes to take things
by force
and any means necessary the way they
operate is also shown in their choice of
suits
as t'challa has the option to pick
either the understated black panther
costume
or the golden one and he goes with the
former killmonger goes with the latter
more ostentatious one because he's
coming out and wants to be seen
whereas t'challa is happy to remain in
the shadows in the first fight that the
two have
t'challa fights with a spear and a
shield whereas killmonger
chooses a spear and a sword showing
their differences in mindset
upon drinking the heart-shaped herb both
characters visit their fathers in the
afterlife
and it's clear that their dads weigh
massively over their heads
the two are pretty much opposite sides
of the same coin and the movie
subtly hints at the similarities between
the two by reusing the iconography of
killmonger holding his father as he dies
which mirrors the way that t'challa held
his during civil war
both parents clearly love their sons and
no more is this exemplified
than when the prince hears noises they
initially panic and cover up everything
and he looks out the window now it may
seem that he's looking for the police
but they would be coming through the
door and instead he's just checking to
make sure that his son's okay
we learned that njobu had been leaking
information on what candidate people
and in age of ultron discovered that
this led to clause storming the country
now marvel tend to do brilliant things
with their timelines
and throughout the movies we often watch
as technology improves
black panther is no different and in the
movie we see how the hologram technology
improves over time
going from a blue image to a fully
realized one
other notable elements to take from this
scene are that njobu kneels before the
king upon its entrance
in infinity war this kneeling is played
for as a joke
but to me it actually shows that
t'challa has become his own man
and won't have the same kind of
leadership that his father did which
eventually led to his own brother
betraying him
now black panther has one of the coolest
costumes in the entire mcu
and when it first made its debut in
civil war
many eagle-eyed viewers noticed that the
suit never made a sound
we learn in this film that this is due
to the sneaking technology in it
and shuri even shows off some new
sneakers for the character
these have a cool little easter egg on
them that redditors have spotted
and if you check out the letters on the
pair of sneakers they actually say air
to chaka
as t'challa is the heir to the throne
now this is a play on the words air
and air tichaka is a play on the famous
sneakers air jordan
she says they are fully automated which
is also a nod to back to the future part
two
black panther's costume stores energy
and this is shown by it lighting up with
purple coloring
in infinity war thanos slams black
panther so hard it actually breaks apart
all the energy stored
and completely releases it showing just
how much that hurt
we can see a test in which they store up
some kinetic energy
and what canon text appears on the torso
which
translates to i love you mom now
superheroes love branding
and we actually see the masks that the
characters use reappear throughout the
film
the black panthers face play is what the
attack ships look like from the bottom
and this is a really cool detail that
shows just how much the creative team
were really looking into the overall
world building killmonger's mask also
appears similar to the dropships
and yeah it's great just seeing these
these little bits of iconography popping
up
we also see scales being worked on in
the lab and these later appear under
captain america's uniform
showing that he may have had a little
help from the wakandans
after dropping off bucky cap visits this
location throughout the mcu twice
and the two scenes mirror one another
very closely
bucky is teased at the end of the movie
which sort of brings all of these
moments together
and i if you watch my other video on
parallels then you'll know i absolutely
love things like this
now speaking of locations in the film we
learned that killmonger is launching
spies in london
hong kong and new york in doctor strange
we discovered that these are the
locations of the sanctum sanctorums
and can gather from this that these are
key locations on the planet
that if taken can likely overthrow the
world on both the physical and spiritual
plane
now one of the best characters in black
panther is ulysses claw
after making his debut in age of ultron
he he makes a much bigger impression
here
and pretty much chews up the scenery
every time he's on screen
in the aforementioned movie when talking
about how he obtained the vibranium
he says it came at great personal cost
and rubs his neck
showing a brand given to him by the
people of wakanda
a dossier in that movie shows that
claw's great grandfather
was actually killed by a previous
version of the black panther
so i love how this rivalry has existed
throughout the ages
at one point in the film when khloe and
killmonger have a shootout
claw actually wins and he hits
killmonger first
however he's wearing body armor and thus
eric is able to gain the upper hand on
him
i tried to do a hand joke there but i
couldn't think of a good one
i guess when it comes to rubbish jokes i
need a hand
now claw in the comics is actually made
of living sound
and this is a reference in the film when
he offers to give agent ross a mixtape
this happens at the casino and upon
entering it the groups say that there
are seven americans there
they managed to locate six when walking
around but there's a seventh that they
can't find
and this is actually stan lee now
another cool moment in the scene
is that the costume design department
deliberately dressed the character in
colors that resemble a pan-african flag
again this ties into the whole costume
design thing and it's great to see it
popping up
now they chase after claw and he blows
up the car
this isn't really an easter egg i just
love the way that the wheel continues to
roll into the next shot
that is attention to detail for you
killmonger goes to rescue him and
t'challa
dives on a grenade to show how much of a
hero that he is
steve rogers of course did this in the
first avenger to prove that he was
willing to sacrifice himself
and this is one of the things that got
him selected for the super soldier
program
now this all leads to killmonger taking
the throne after beating t'challa
during the fight killmonger breaks his
spear which makes it very short
the shakazulu of south africa actually
used to use this fighting style quite
often
as it improved their chances of killing
more people due to the speed that they
could wield it at
killmonger's face is cut during the
fight but the next time we see him
this is actually healed this is because
of the science department at the kingdom
which is also able to heal the bullet
wound in agent ross very quickly
like wolverine's speed almost killmonger
picks up t'challa
and throws him over a waterfall to his
apparent death
now what i love about t'challa is that
he often says things that
ironically backfire on him this is of
course shown in there
i never freeze thing that we did
terribly at the start
but there are other examples too in
infinity war
black panther tells the black order that
thanos will have nothing but dust and
blood
this literally happens as tony manages
to get a drop of blood from the
character
and after thanos carries out the snap
everyone turns to dust
so he did he did have nothing but dust
and blood he also says that this is no
place to die
before dying himself and yeah just just
be careful what you say mate
now killmonger ends up taking the throne
and he wears his father's ring on his
hand
rather than round his neck showing that
he's finally completed his mission
throughout the throne room scenes we can
actually see that there's an empty chair
and this is because umbaku refuses to
join the council and prefers to live in
the mountains
he does end up helping t'challa incar
fight back and this leads to a big
battle at the vibranium mining facility
we can actually see that the jabaris
don't use any vibranium
and this is because the group reject the
metal due to their beliefs
they actually wish to take wakanda back
to its roots and thus
they they just want to make things
simple for themselves now this finale is
a big battle
that sees everett ross piloting one of
the ships he used to be a pilot
and thus surely sets up the control
panel to be similar to an f-16
which uses a hands on the throttle and
stick setup to guide it
t'challa manages to beat killmonger and
he takes him out to see the sunset
after becoming king killmonger actually
said the sun will never set on the
wakandan empire
but he must have been learning lessons
from t'challa because
as the sun sets the character dies along
with his empire
if you ever become a black panther just
keep your mouth shut for the entire time
now after returning to oakland we get
the credits scene
in which the colors actually represent
all of the infinity stones this was of
course put in place to tease the next
film in the release schedule
which was infinity war and i appreciate
its ucl also the music's really good
anyway that's our entire list of things
we spotted
and also yeah did anyone notice that the
queen knows
that shuri did something behind her back
because of t'challa's expression when
she sticks her fingers up
just just zoom in and look at his little
face now i know this didn't contain
absolutely everything but there's just
been so many breakdowns and
i just wanted to talk about things that
i hadn't really seen people mentioning
before
obviously let me know if you think
anything should have made the list
and if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up and make sure
you check out our breakdown of into the
spider verse which is going to be linked
at the end
if you want to support the channel and
get to see some content early then
please consider clicking the join button
below
we massively appreciate it and it helps
it so that videos like this can get made
and that i also don't have to get a
proper job and
you could also come chat to us on our
discord server link below or at heavy
spoilers on twitter
but we're all out of the way thank you
for making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next time take
care much love
peace
[Music]
you